Los negocios generan esos recursos
cuando obtienen ganancias.
Esas ganancias son la pequeña diferencia
entre el precio y los gastos necesarios para producir
cualquier solución que haya creado una empresa
para cualquier problema que tratan de resolver.
Pero esa ganancia es la magia.
¿Por qué? Porque esa ganancia permite que cualquier solución
que hayamos creado
sea infinitamente escalable.
Porque si podemos tener una ganancia,
podemos multiplicarla por 10, por 100, por un millón,
100 millones, mil millones.
La solución se vuelve autosostenible.
Eso es lo que hacen los negocios
cuando hay ganancia.
Ahora, ¿qué tiene que ver todo esto
con los problemas sociales?
Bueno, una forma de pensar es tomar esa ganancia
y redistribuirla a los problemas sociales.
Las empresas deberían dar más.
Las empresas deben ser más responsables.
Ese ha sido el camino que hemos seguido
en los negocios.
Una vez más, el camino que hemos seguido
no nos está llevando a donde tenemos que ir.
Empecé como profesor de estrategia,
y todavía lo soy.
Estoy orgulloso de ello.
Pero con los años,
he trabajado cada vez más con problemas sociales.
He trabajado en salud, en medio ambiente,
en desarrollo económico, en la reducción de la pobreza,
y mientras trabajaba cada vez más en el ámbito social
comencé a ver algo
que me impactó significativamente
y repercutió en mi vida.
La sabiduría convencional en economía
y la visión de negocio ha sido históricamente
la de que existe una compensación
entre el desempeño social y el rendimiento económico.
La sabiduría convencional nos dice
que los negocios obtienen ganancias
causando problemas sociales.
El ejemplo clásico es la contaminación.
Si el negocio contamina, gana más dinero
que si intenta reducir esa contaminación.
Reducir la contaminación es muy costoso,
por eso las empresas no quieren hacerlo.
Resulta rentable tener un entorno de trabajo poco seguro.
Es demasiado caro tener un entorno de trabajo seguro,
por eso los negocios ganan más
si el entorno laboral no es seguro.
Esa ha sido la idea convencional.
Muchas empresas han caído en esa idea convencional.
Se resisten a mejorar el medio ambiente.
Se resisten a mejorar del entorno laboral.
Esa forma de pensar ha conducido, creo,
a buena parte del comportamiento
que hemos llegado a criticar en los negocios,
que yo mismo he llegado a criticar.
Pero, cuanto más me metía en todos estos problemas sociales,
uno tras otro,
y en realidad, cuanto más intentaba hacerles frente,
personalmente, en algunos casos,
a través de organizaciones a las que pertenecía,
estaba cada vez más convencido de que la realidad
es todo lo contrario.
Las empresas no obtienen ganancias
causando problemas sociales,
al menos no en sentido fundamental.
Esa es una visión muy simplista.
Cuanto más nos metemos en estos temas,
mejor podemos entender
que las empresas realmente generan ganancias
cuando solucionan problemas sociales.
De ahí viene la verdadera ganancia.
Por ejemplo, la contaminación.
Hemos aprendido hoy que en realidad
reducir la contaminación y las emisiones
genera ganancias.
Ahorra dinero.
Hace que el negocio sea más productivo y eficiente.
No malgasta recursos.
Tener un entorno de trabajo más seguro
y evitar los accidentes,
hace que el negocio sea más rentable,
porque es una muestra de buenos procedimientos.
Los accidentes son caros y costosos.
Problema tras problema, empezamos a entender
que en realidad no hay compensación
entre el progreso social
y la eficiencia económica
en ningún sentido fundamental.
Otra cuestión es la salud.
Es decir, lo que hemos descubierto en realidad
es que la salud de los empleados es algo
que una empresa debe atesorar,
porque la salud permite que esos empleados
sean más productivos y puedan trabajar
y no estén ausentes.
El trabajo más profundo, el nuevo trabajo, el nuevo pensamiento
en la interfaz entre las empresas y los problemas sociales;
en realidad está demostrando que hay una sinergia
fundamental y profunda,
especialmente si no estás pensando en el corto plazo.
En muy corto plazo, puedes a veces
engañarte pensando
que fundamentalmente hay objetivos opuestos,
pero a la larga, en última instancia, estamos aprendiendo
área tras área, que esto simplemente no es cierto.
Entonces, ¿cómo podríamos usar
el poder de los negocios
para abordar los problemas fundamentales
que enfrentamos?
Imagínense que si podemos hacerlo,
podríamos escalar.
Podríamos aprovechar esta enorme reserva de recursos
y esta capacidad organizativa.
Y, adivinen qué. Está ocurriendo ahora mismo, finalmente.
En parte gracias a personas como ustedes
que están planteando estas cuestiones,
año tras año y década tras década.
Vemos a organizaciones como Dow Chemical
liderando la revolución para eliminar las grasas trans
y las grasas saturadas con productos nuevos e innovadores.
Este es un ejemplo de Jain Irrigation.
Esta es una empresa que ha traído la tecnología del riego por goteo
a miles y millones de campesinos,
reduciendo sustancialmente el uso de agua.
Vemos a empresas como la compañía forestal brasileña Fibria
que descubrió cómo evitar
la tala de bosques antiguos.
Usa el eucalipto y consigue mucho más rendimiento
por hectárea de pulpa
y produce más papel que lo podría lograr
talando árboles viejos.
Ves a empresas como Cisco que ha entrenado
hasta el momento a 4 millones de personas en informática,
siendo realmente responsable
al ayudar a expandir las oportunidades
al difundir la tecnología informática
y hacer crecer toda la empresa.
Hoy existe una oportunidad fundamental para las empresas
de impactar y lidiar con estos problemas sociales.
Esta oportunidad
es la del negocio más grande
que vemos en el mundo real.
La pregunta es, ¿cómo hacer para que las empresas
quieran adoptar el tema del valor compartido?
Esto es lo que llamo valor compartido:
Abordar un tema social con un modelo de negocio.
Eso es valor compartido.
Valor compartido es capitalismo,
pero en su forma más avanzada.
Es el capitalismo como debe ser verdaderamente,
satisfaciendo necesidades importantes,
sin competir por pequeñeces,
por diferencias triviales en las características del producto
y en las cuotas del mercado.
Valor compartido es cuando podemos crear valor social
y valor económico al mismo tiempo.
Es encontrar esas oportunidades
que desatarán nuestras mejores posibilidades
para abordar problemas sociales
porque así podemos escalar.
Podemos abordar el valor compartido en muchos niveles.
Es real. Está sucediendo.
Pero para lograr que esta solución funcione,
tenemos que cambiar la forma como las empresas se ven a sí mismas,
y esto afortunadamente ya está en marcha.
Muchas empresas se han quedado atrapadas en la idea convencional
de que no deberían preocuparse por los problemas sociales,
porque esto era algo periférico,
que alguien más debería hacer.
Ahora se ven empresas
que aceptan la idea.
Pero también tenemos que reconocer que las empresas
no lo van a hacer con tanta eficacia
si no logran que las ONGs y el gobierno
trabajen en colaboración con ellas.
Las nuevas ONGs que realmente hacen la diferencia
son las que han conseguido estas cooperaciones,
que han encontrado estas maneras de colaborar.
Los gobiernos que han logrado un mayor avance
son los que han encontrado maneras
de habilitar el valor compartido en los negocios
en lugar de ver al gobierno como el único responsable
en la toma de decisiones.
Y el gobierno tiene muchas maneras de influenciar
la voluntad y la capacidad de las empresas
para competir de esta forma.
Creo que si hacemos que los negocios se vean a sí mismos de forma diferente,
y logran que otros los vean de forma diferente,
podemos cambiar el mundo.
Lo sé. Lo veo.
Lo siento.
Creo que los jóvenes,
mis estudiantes de Harvard Business School, lo están entendiendo.
Si podemos romper esta brecha,
esta inquietud, esta tensión,
este sentido de que no estamos
fundamentalmente colaborando aquí
en la conducción de estos problemas sociales,
podemos resolverlo,
y creo que, finalmente,
hallaremos las soluciones.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)